People die every day.
Why not give nature a helping hand?
It's just prime for, for funny you know.
I mean, these are normal women doing something mad.
And with no skill set.
Right, it's like the most ridiculous thing.
It's a comedy and it's a drama.
Set and shot in Ireland.
Essentially it's a story of a family of sisters.
One of them, Grace, is married to a diabolical,
terrible human.
Break these in for me will you? Just,
wear them round the house.
Her sisters can see that they're losing her and
if they don't do something soon,
she's going to be gone.
So they decide to try and kill him.
The connections between the five of
them, is really endlessly entertaining.
I think for anyone who has siblings,
there's going to be lots of things that
resonate and are painful and funny.
So you go everywhere together?
Well, we're close.
Like a pack.
Like a family.
Eva is the matriarch.
Their parents died when they were young.
She decided she'd look out for the girls.
And sort of parked her life.
Bibi would be the meticulous planner.
I don't want to hear the ins and outs of grotting someone.
Why?
She's the best at murder.
The youngest has never really gotten her life together.
There's a wildness to them both that the others don't have.
Remind me never to interrogate why
Bibi seems to be just naturally gifted at this.
Ursula has three kids, a very devoted husband.
She's trying to keep lots of plates spinning.
Grab your stuff and get in the car. You don't
need to take things off the table!
Sort of highly strung at times.
You don't really know who Grace is in a way.
She has that odd veneer because she's in
so much denial about what's really happening.
Get a grip of yourself.
There's a lot of control inside the
relationship. There's a lot of gaslighting.
He just can't deal with the fact that she's
part of this very strong group.
I mean nobody's out to get him in that sense.
- No, baby they're not.
- I mean, no.
- Or are they?
- Well, I mean,
They are, now!
Being both funny and sad,
it has to be one of Sharon Horgan's greatest gifts.
I always feel like comedy deals with
really serious topics really well.
And it's so hard to act.
Yeah!
When we are all together, that's
when it just totally comes alive.
Come on!
It's pretty crazy at times.
But there's a real beating heart at the center of it.
We'll just look at for each other like we always have.
They would do anything for each other.
They would kill for each other.
Families they're...
complex.